[Music]
good morning everybody we've had gaps on
supermarket shelves for weeks now some
petrol stations are being forced to
close
for the same reason a shortage of hgv
drivers the government insists there's
no need to panic by as there's no actual
shortage of fuel but there's increasing
criticism that ministers should have
done more to avert the crisis shaman
freeman power reports
supermarkets oil companies and major
retailers are clear
they're running short of one thing lorry
drivers
companies say they have plenty of
produce for everyone but not enough
drivers to deliver it
it's an issue of supply and demand bp
says it cannot supply the petrol because
there is such a high demand for hgv
drivers forcing them to ration fuel and
close shops where that's not possible
the issues driving this crisis are
complex brexit the pandemic and an aging
population are just some of the issues
that play here many non-uk workers went
home drivers are even faster than they
can be recruited
and the pandemic caused delays to the
hgv tests but this could just be the
start
there are easier jobs in the world to do
than driving a truck it's a tough job
it's expensive job to train
there's no early end in sight to this
we'll probably be having to live with a
trucker shortage for at least another
year or so even if the government
tackles the issue urgently which they
haven't really up to now
this is all happening as winter is
coming and it may be one of discontent
the whole movement of food logistics
around the uk getting things from farms
to processing uh factories from the
processors off to the warehouses and
from the warehouses to the shops and
without the hgv drivers with a glue of
that process
it is not possible for consumers to get
the products on the shelves that they
need
industry insiders are urging the
government to provide temporary work
visas to encourage drivers to return
if not they say we can expect to see a
return of panic buying over coming weeks
shimon freeman powell sky news
grant schnapps transport secretary
joining us now mr
good morning good of you to join us this
morning what's your advice to motorists
at the pump today
um advice would be carry on as normal
and that's what bp are saying as well um
they describe it on the average day that
they have a handful
of petrol stations that they have to
close out of 12 or 1300 and the
problem's not new there's been a lack of
drivers
actually for many months through this
pandemic because as your report just
said uh during the lockdown drivers
couldn't be passed through their lorry
hev tests and that's what's led to this
problem
but many more tests are being made
available now
so we should see it smooth out
fairly quickly
not according to the rhode haulage
association they say it's another year
of um angst
yeah there's a difference between um
the this specific issue in the very
short term and the much longer term uh
issues because in fact in point of fact
i was talking to the the chief executive
of uh the largest uh rhode haulage uh uh
organization logistics uk i think he
said he's been in the job for five years
and the very first thing on his desk was
was the shortage of uh lorry drivers and
it's never gone away that said most
people won't have ever noticed that so
there's a difference between what is a
systemic shortage which we want to deal
with but also the shorter term problem
of people not having been able to take
their tests during coronavirus for
understandable reasons and the number of
new tests that we've now made available
by doubling the supply of those tests
uh it would be disingenuous to say
that's the only reason
um well kovid is the main reason it's a
global problem and europe has hit
particularly bad uh we've got for
example in germany a 60 000 shortage in
poland a 123 000 shortage of lorry
drivers um so it is as i said is the the
principal cause of the problem and we're
working very hard to change it including
changing the laws in order to provide
more tests for hgv drivers and
encouraging people to come back into the
into the market but you're right there
are longer term problems which is it's a
difficult uh
a long day's work it's a hard work it's
a skilled job and actually it's been
underpaid up until now so we very much
welcome the salaries going up the wages
going up and that's attracting more
people back to the sector a quick fix
would be short-term visa for drivers in
europe to come to the
uk i'll look at everything and we'll
move the heaven and earth to do whatever
we can to
make sure that shortages are alleviated
with hgv drivers but uh we we need to
look at things which are going to make a
difference and the big problem is the
the testing of drivers coming in you get
an attrition rate people retire if you
can't get new people in and we we were
unable to test 40 000 drivers during
coronavirus that's the principal um
problem uh and of course there are
already six million eu nationals with
settled and pre-settled status some of
whom will already be eligible to to
drive uh enticing them to come here is
really the highest salary
and we just need to make sure that the
tests can be passed if people have
perhaps have an expired license but want
to get back to driving a lorry
move heaven and earth to get them to
come here reports this morning in the
newspapers that the environment
secretary wants these visas for skilled
workers to um have a short-term visa for
lorry drivers from europe you and the
home secretary do not is there any truth
in that story
no actually we're one on this i think
he's actually talking about the seasonal
workers um scheme specifically and as i
said i wouldn't rule out doing something
or you know any of measures that are
possible to take for lorry drivers my
point is that over a long period of time
what we've done in this country is rely
on importing cheap european often
eastern european labor undercutting the
domestic market and creating more
long-term problems that we end up never
actually getting out of this cycle which
is to say has existed for years i
welcome the fact that you know lorry
drivers are able to attract a better
salary and that's what we need including
better conditions as well and you know
99
of lorry drivers in this country are
white male average age 55
we we need to make this a more
attractive
industry to go into and and the solution
to that is to have those slightly higher
wages and better conditions at truck
stops and the like as well
um
these short-term visas these specialist
skilled worker visas ballerinas are on
the list and hgv drivers are not
well as i say
i wouldn't rule anything out here but
what i don't want to do is exactly but
that's absurd
yeah
but the difference here is that the real
problem that we face and we know this
because as soon as the tests become
available they are snapped up
immediately the real bottleneck in all
of this is testing that is where we need
to relieve it you've made the point as
far as that's concerned mr champs were
talking about bringing in drivers in the
interim to try and fix this problem
we're 110 000 drivers short there are
drivers 14 000 drivers went home during
the pandemic only 600 have come back by
any maths you know there's a good ten
thousand even with slippage who could
come back and at least try to help in
the short term they can't get a skill
worker uh visa but a ballerina can
i should say those numbers are hotly
debated but only go into all of that um
what i would say is we've got six
million uh as i say eu settled and
pre-settled status many of those people
can already drive we've also got
hundreds of thousands of brits who are
able to drive and are being attracted
back so
we'll do whatever it takes as a setup
we'll move heaven and earth and i'll
look at any feasible scheme we've
already taken measures which have
doubled the number of tests available
including changing the law um so we're
using every lever at our disposal to to
do this uh are you gonna look at the
skill worker visa is that what you're
saying
absolutely not ruling anything out at
all we want to see this problem resolved
but i also want to see it resolve for
the long term not just a short-term fix
which ends up exacerbating the long term
as well how many four courts were
affected this morning
well out of bp's uh 12 or 1300 for four
courts uh yesterday they told me that
five had to be closed throughout the
country and say there's no shortage of
vp that supplies fuel though is there
bp and um tesco the others morrisons and
uh as uh and other supermarkets are
saying they have no problems as have
other uh petrol companies so it has been
quite a defined problem this is not a
shortage of fuel at the refineries uh
and it's not something new in fact when
people don't matter if it is or not if
you can't get it from the refinery as as
tony blair found out all those years ago
you can't get it from the refinery to
the forecourt it doesn't matter where
the problem is that was different
because they had massive numbers of uh
of hgv drivers not working there was an
actual strike there was a blockade it
was a very different situation yeah but
the point is they couldn't get it from
the refinery to the forecourt that's a
similar going to be a similar problem if
we can't get more drivers my question to
you is transport secretary this morning
is how many four courts are affected
well as i say five yesterday on the bp
ball courts the point was going to make
though uh okay
only five petrol stations four courts in
the whole country that's impacted
of bp yesterday that's the case but okay
the point that's going to happen
let's clarify this point because you're
saying that there isn't an issue uh all
the front pages this morning are saying
that there is an issue the petrol
retailers association is saying that
there is an issue they're saying keep a
quarter of a tank in your um keep a
quarter of fuel in your tank just in
case you can't get any so all of these
people are wrong and you're saying
there's only five at petrol stations
affected i want to answer this very
precisely so i appreciate it if you just
give me 10 seconds to do that one i'm
not saying there's no issue there has
been an issue and that's what was
reported on two the conversations that
were reported out and are in today's
paper are from over a week ago and
referred to the situation over the
previous three months so what people can
see is that although there are stresses
and strains in the system by and large
it had not impacted on people's
everyday life when it came to filling up
with petrol now what we need to make
sure is that we can continue to have
more people capable of driving and
therefore continue to alleviate the
problem or move heaven and earth to do
that
how many petrol stations four courts are
affected this morning as transport
secretary you must know
so i'm afraid i don't have the answers
to that at seven a.m in the morning what
i can do what was it ten o'clock last
night
uh as of last night five petrol stations
on bp network of or 1300 were affected
and i'm meeting this morning with tesco
and i'm sure they'll give me the update
for themselves and none of the other
retailers said that they had any
closures
um how much is brexit to blame
well i've seen people point to brexit as
if it's the uh the culprit here in fact
they're wrong uh not only are there uh
very large and even larger shortages in
other eu countries like poland and
germany which clearly can't be to do
with brexit but actually because of
brexit i've been able to change the law
and alter the way that our driving tests
operate in a way that i could not have
done if we were still part of the eu so
brexit actually has provided part of the
solution of giving more
slots available for hgv tests and a lot
more twice as many tests available now
than before the pandemic a large
proportion of those i've only been able
to do because we're no longer actually
in the eu okay how are you feeling about
civil servants working from home
london tech week conference uh yesterday
sarah healey um said that she enjoys
working from home she's a top mandarin
so she because she can spend more time
on her peloton exercise bike
well look i think we're in a world now
um where people where there is a
combination people were working from
home people are going into the office i
i had a look at you i know some the last
week for which i have numbers there are
about 1
300 uh transport official
civil servants in the
in the office i i i've been in this
weekend people are pleased to to come
back to the office there will be times
when people want to work from home we
are in this sort of transition um stage
through the uh through the autumn um and
uh and i i think things will settle down
into uh probably more of a hybrid world
but there's nothing like the spark of
being in the office um as as a lot of my
team found this this last week or two
although you find it very productive
being working from home don't you
minister can never get you in here can
we i'd be loving love to come and see
you
when when when when when oh well it's as
soon as you invite me on again okay i'd
like to okay we'll see you next week
sometimes i i i i do find genuinely um
that it's helpful to be in the office
there are times where uh it's quite nice
to be at home when you're um on the
radio first thing
okay um and on the telly box uh talk to
me about lateral flow test before i let
you go and there were some suggestions
that the pcrs would be replaced by
lateral flow tests when in time for
uh half term holidays for the kids i was
reading yesterday that there aren't
enough lateral flow tests and there
aren't enough people who will be able to
supervise those lateral flow tests via
zoom or whatever and so that's not going
to happen is that wrong
i don't think that's right this is my
colleagues over at the department of
health we've been working very hard on
this and i know they've got the the date
of half term uh in mind um we did need
to give the uh producers of these things
some time because of course they've been
busily producing pcr tests over the
summer um to switch production to
lateral flow um but uh it looks to me
like like they'll be able to step up to
that i noticed actually in ireland um
yesterday uh that little came along with
a pack of uh which they're selling in
their stores in in in the republic there
for 25 euros and you get five lateral
flow tests
i you know look forward to the expansion
of lateral flow test perhaps into
supermarkets and elsewhere
as we as we get on to the point where
people can buy those for returning from
holiday so you think a little lateral
flow test should be accepted as um
currency enough or does it have to be a
little bit more formal than that
well it will be for the department of
health to to set out the rules about how
people need to go about this but
remember with pcr tests
you didn't have to be
supervised as it were you had to get
that pcr test in advance you had to
record the fact that you ordered it uh
but you were then trusted to get on and
do it obviously the department of health
will put some guidance in place as to
how they want this to operate and
they're still working on that so i went
tread on their toes but i i've every
confidence that the system would be gone
up and running uh in good time
but you're still uh hopeful that the
lateral flow um ruling will be in place
for the half-term holidays i i am as i
say they're working on the detail of
this and the the private market is
having to respond to
uh that shift to using lateral flows and
of course they'd need hundreds of
thousands even millions of them
available so and there's a there's a big
task for that but i know my colleagues
are working hard on that
okay the team will ring you later about
coming on next week in the studio thanks
very much for joining us i said next
week but i look forward to being there
okay
lovely thank you
thank you still to come on the program
before you secure stammer under pressure
over his planned reforms for labour will
speak to his party chair annalise dodds
just after have passed seven
raising thousands over a cuppa and some
cake we'll talk to two fundraisers for
mcmillan's cancer coffee morning at 7 45
and he's only been here for a month
america's top man in the uk ambassador
philip t rica joining us for an
exclusive tv interview at 8 35.
police are questioning a man in
connection with the murder of the
teacher sabine nessa in london they've
also released images of another man who
they want to speak with in connection
with her death either bennett reports
this is the man police would like to
speak to as they continue their hunt for
sabina nessa's killer he was seen on
cctv in an area close to where she was
attacked last friday
police have also released this image of
a car they're trying to trace which they
believe the man has access to
in a separate development a 38 year old
man has been arrested on suspicion of
murder
the park where sabina was killed is
outside her home in southeast london
hundreds are expected at a vigil there
tonight to call for an end to violence
against women
we are supporting the local women in
kibbrook to
come together to
remember sabine to say that their
community is not a violent place but
also to stand up against violence
against women and girls and say that
women changing their behavior isn't the
answer that we need more fundamental
changes to keep the women safe
the 28 year old primary school teacher
was murdered in a park just outside her
home in southeast london a cause of
death still hasn't been established nor
has a motive
police forensics are focused around a
community center in the middle of cater
park in kidbrook village it's minutes
from sabine's flat which she left at 8
30 on friday night
she was on her way to meet a friend at
the depot bar just five minutes away but
never made it her body was found by a
dog walker the following afternoon
it's really upsetting um to think that
someone
living so local
just going to the same pub i've
literally just come from
yes quite shocking really
sabine lived in that building there it
overlooks the park this is the path she
walked on that cuts through the middle
of the park her body was found
just behind those trees there it's
barely a hundred meters from where she
lived practically on her doorstep
the path is lit at night but many
residents say they avoid walking here
after dark because they don't feel safe
i keep looking at single men believe it
or not i'm thinking oh
i'm not the murderer
that's just a natural instinct but um
because there's so many people about i i
feel okay but i'm nervous still does it
make you think twice about coming here
at night oh i won't come here overnight
never
downing street said the prime minister's
focus is on making streets safe for
everybody but labor say it's not enough
and want violence against women to be
treated like terrorism
we see piecemeal
a little pilot here a review done there
when in reality we need a whole scale
system change that prioritizes violence
against women and girls the way we
prioritize terrorism in this country
police insist the streets of the capital
are safe for women but for many here
they are words that offer little
reassurance iva bennett sky news kid
brooke
fears of more damage is lava from a
volcanic eruption on the canary islands
reaches as high as 50 feet in places
officials say eruptions seem to be
decreasing
forgive me
has the latest from la palma
it is now day six on the island and the
volcano behind me the cumbre vieja
continues to spit out that hot molten
rock it is splintering and it is
spitting so ferociously that we've not
just seen those thick ash clouds rising
into the air but we've also seen the
continuation of that hot lava pouring
out and now we know that we we know
there have been more registered
explosions um late afternoon and again
it looks even more ferocious today and
arguably we could see the same thing
happening uh later on giant boulders are
completely a tumbling from it we know
that some of that rock is firing some a
thousand feet into the air we now know
there are two rivers of lava and at
their meeting point we know it stretches
some 600 meters but it has is as
spectacular as it is destructive um we
know that that thick smog that it is
causing to rise up into the air is now
threatening airspace we have heard about
delays at la palma airport only
yesterday it's likely we'll see similar
scenes happening today of course the
challenge now really is to get those
residents to get those local people back
to safety back to places where they can
actually call home we went to a donation
center yesterday and we saw everything
from items of clothing to toiletries to
bedding people in this community have
really rallied round and put their arms
around each other because they know that
something like this doesn't happen very
often the last time it exploded was 15
years ago so of 50 years ago i should
say so they know that this is such an
extraordinary moment in history that
people are going to need all the help
they can get and what we saw yesterday
was an extraordinary commun community
effort but the real worry now is that
there are
there is a shortage of rental
accommodation that many people are being
housed in at least temporary forms of
accommodation things like hotels but
something more permanent will urgently
need to be found for them
also making news for us this morning
here on sky parts of southern spain have
been hit by record rainfall and floods
the president of andalusia has declared
a public emergency after dozens of homes
and businesses were badly damaged
derek chovin the former police officer
jail for the murder of george floyd has
launched an appeal against his
conviction he was jailed for 22 and a
half years early this year after being
convicted of murder and manslaughter
warning that thousands of cancer
patients in england could die over the
next decade because of backlog of cancer
diagnosis and treatment the institute
for public policy research says more
than 19 000 people are living with
undiagnosed cancer due to
misappointments
claimed england is on track to have
diagnosed 95 percent of people living
with hiv by 2025.
public health england says the
development makes it possible to
eliminate transmission in england by
2030.
very quick look at the weather the next
few days for you are going to bring some
light rain to the north and west before
turning more unsettled from sunday
now as part of the build-up to the new
james bond movie the royal navy has
decided to honour the actor who
currently plays britain's most famous
spy
daniel craig shares something else with
james bond the rank of commander he was
presented with the honour by the head of
the navy first sea lord admiral tony
radekin there he is there they are it
comes ahead of the premier of no time to
die craig's last outing as double07 and
i cannot wait to watch that next week
what about you let me know you're
looking forward to it too at k burley if
you would like to tweet me directly now
the labour party conference begins in
brighton tomorrow party chair annelise
dodds joins us in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone the transport secretary
grant shouts has told us that he'll do
everything in his power to resolve the
lack of hgv drivers which is now forced
some petrol stations to close but he
hasn't committed to extending the
skilled worker visa
scheme to recruit drivers from outside
the uk
i'll look at everything and we'll move
the heaven and earth to do whatever we
can to um make sure that shortages are
uh alleviated with uh hgv drivers but uh
we we need to look at things which are
going to make a difference and the big
problem is that the testing of drivers
coming in you get an attrition rate
people retire if you can't get new
people in and we we were unable to test
40 000 drivers during coronavirus that's
the principal um problem
but the transport secretary rejected
suggestions that brexit is to blame for
a shortage of drivers the road haulage
association has called for those
temporary visas to allow more foreign
drivers to work in the uk but grant
champs told us brexit just wasn't to
blame
i've seen people point to brexit as if
it's the uh the culprit here in fact
they're wrong not only are there
very large and even larger shortages in
other eu countries like poland and
germany which clearly can't be to do
with brexit but actually because of
brexit i've been able to change the law
and alter the way that our driving tests
operate in a way that i could not have
done if we were still part of the eu so
brexit actually has provided part of the
solution of giving more uh slots
available for hgv tests and a lot more
twice as many tests available now than
before the pandemic a large proportion
of those i've only been able to do
because we're no longer actually in the
eu
well labour's unveiled an ambitious plan
for more affordable housing that's ahead
of its annual conference which starts um
tomorrow talk about that and other
things with the chair of the party
annelise dodds hello to ms dos thanks
for joining us uh on the programme this
morning uh just uh picking up off the
back of grant shaps there he was saying
nothing to worry about as far as fuel
shortages are concerned do you feel
reassured
well unfortunately i don't and i think
there are families up and down the
country who are really concerned about
this of course they're looking at their
family finances
anticipating or already being impacted
by those increases in fuel costs of
course they'll also see national
insurance going up now as well and
potentially universal credit being cut
if they're one of those many families in
the uk who are working and having to top
that up with universal credit this is a
real triple hammer blow that we're
seeing on people's finances right now
and government could act on this they
could act swiftly they could for example
reverse that cut to universal credit
they should instead target that tax
burden much more on those with the
broader shoulders and they could do
things like for example automatically
switch on the warm home support that
people need of course in the longer term
we really need to see the government
grasping the nettle of more resilient
energy supply something that for example
rachel reeves has been pushing for for a
long time but that's immediate measures
that the government could take now to
get our country to a better place
all of that said and um
the fact that it's your party conference
and starting this weekend labour has
only put up
two out of five days politicians to come
to talk to us and rebut what the
government has had to say for itself
what sort of message do you think that
sends to my viewers
well okay you know that i'm always keen
to speak with you
yes and it's fantastic that you're here
my point is that there are three other
days out of the five this week where
your colleagues could have come on and
made the robust points that you just
have
especially ahead of your party
conference especially because your
leader is trying to reboot the party and
it's an open goal that you don't take so
i suppose my viewers might think that
you're in somewhat of a disarray
well i have to say okay i don't know
what went on there but i would say
without going into too many details i
last week had norovirus i wonder whether
there was something like that that might
have cropped up and maybe meant that
there was an issue there and certainly
as i say i'm very keen to always appear
because i really want to make sure that
labour is having that dialogue with your
viewers i think that's incredibly
important so
i'm sure that it was more to do with uh
some kind of logistical issues rather
than anything uh more serious than that
well as party chairman i hope that is
the case and that we'll see more of your
colleagues next week are you feeling
better now
bless you i really am yes yes absolutely
but
yeah i really feel for anybody who who
does get that who's got existing health
conditions uh quite grim unfortunately
you're here also to talk about the
housing crisis and what labour plans to
do to tackle that
absolutely and i think we've seen that
situation in housing getting harder and
harder for families up and down our
country of course we've seen the rate of
homeownership going down very
substantially particularly within the
under 45s so labour's saying now that we
can radically change things here you
know first of all we can have those
requirements for affordable housing that
actually means something at the moment
the government's definition of
affordability
relates to the overall market cost of
housing that's so far out of many
people's reach that it's pretty much
meaningless we said instead that we
would peg that affordability to actually
people's wages to the money that they've
got coming in that would make so much
more sense it would really force
developers to be providing far more
genuinely affordable housing that people
really need we've also said that for
those first-time buyers they should be
able to have the first chance when
there's a new development with that new
housing that they should have the first
chance to be able to get that first run
on the housing ladder that's so
important and as i said with those rates
of home ownership going down in our
country it's really important that we do
help people to get that security okay
hdv drivers not enough of them more than
a hundred thousand sure nothing to do
with brexit is what the transport
secretary says
well i wish the transport secretary
would actually be taking action for the
future we've got a difficult situation
right now but when i talk with business
they're not only worried about the
situation now they're very concerned
about what will happen in just a few
months when we'll see a new veterinary
situation coming into play because the
uk has not got that agreement with the
eu on veterinary standards that could
mean big big delays but we also have
much more customs bureaucracy coming in
at the start of next year as well and
again the government doesn't seem to
have any plan really what people like
grant chaps with all respect to him need
to be doing is engaging with business
right now listening to them
understanding the problems and taking
action because this already difficult
situation could actually get even more
intense unless they start to get a grip
so you accept though that he says that
it's nothing to do with brexit
well there are shortages of hgv drivers
in other countries i mean i have to say
that there have however been big
failures in planning for this situation
and the additional red tape that's been
created which was not inevitable it was
not an inevitable result of brexit in
many cases but that hasn't been tackled
by government you know i talk to
advanced manufacturers
in my patch for example and they tell me
that now they've got to fill in you know
dozens of pages of paperwork that's
quite a tall order for an hgv driver if
they've got to be dealing with all of
that as well as getting goods from one
place to another so undoubtedly the
government's method of implementing
brexit has had an impact overall on the
system but there are other factors that
are in play here and i think their
failure to consider you know whether
they need to ask that migration advisory
committee about a different approach to
shortage occupations you know i really
do think that they should be engaging
with business on this and listening to
them
okay um it is the party conference as i
said um end of the week and into next
week um the leader came up with his 14
000 word vision not sure how well it
landed uh to the extent where ian lavery
mp speaking to us here on the programme
uh yesterday or sky news yesterday i
should say saying there's a one in five
chance that kiersten could be gone by
the end of the year
well i think that's a slightly strange
comment for ian to make with all due
respect to him and i do get on with ian
but i think that kiers essie was a
really strong attempt to say look we've
come through this crisis together as a
country it has been incredibly difficult
but we've actually seen what we can do
we've seen how we can work together for
example to support each other to create
that vaccine to build those ventilators
we've seen what our country can do
and here in that essay we're saying how
can we face up to those new challenges
of the future with what we know now
about what the british people british
business british trade unions what they
can do
together um so if any of your viewers
have the time i would really recommend
that they do read that essay i think
those thousands of words will pass
pretty quickly because it's a really
engaging read
okay thank you thanks a lot
thanks very much thank you take care
tomorrow cohen is um hey hi tomorrow
interesting uh comments there from
annelise stores and indeed grant shops
earlier
yes she's saying that the government's
handling of brexit has contributed to
this lorry driver shortage which is
causing problems that what grant shap
says is a handful of four courts people
shouldn't panic or go and try and buy
panic by petrol he says people should
buy petrol as normal but he'll be trying
to keep across the situation today to
see if any more are affected
he says the government is doing a lot to
try and
get more hgv drivers through the system
to tackle the backlog of tests that
built up
during covid but clearly this is a
long-term issue we've got 100 000
vacancies there and you've already got
conservative mps saying we should look
at getting visas so that lorry drivers
who are not currently considered skilled
workers in the post-brexit immigration
system are able to come safe for a year
to
cover the period while we try and train
up uk drivers and labor saying that they
would support that kind of measure okay
for now tomorrow thank you let's find
out what's happening as far as the sport
is concerned with jackie
ah record breakers me too world's
slowest dog
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by the vitality running world cup
[Music]
so emma many congratulations what does
it feel like to be home yeah it's a
really nice feeling to be home i have
been able to spend some time with my
parents after not seeing them for seven
weeks so
we we just had a nice meal together last
night with some homemade dumplings and
i've re-watched the final just to just
to relive some experiences and what was
that like were you tense re-watching the
final yeah i just really wanted to let
the moment sink in and i thought that
would help
but um it i knew exactly what it was
going to happen in all of the points but
watching is definitely more stressful
than playing because you feel like you
have control at least when you're
playing when you're watching
um you you have no control and
but it was really cool to just be able
to
relive some of those moments and at the
end i i saw my slide when i fell and uh
it was quite long and i actually
impressed myself with that in slow
motion
it was a very impressive slide when you
saw your mum and dad for the first time
you know what did they say to you
because well played doesn't really cover
it does it
yeah they just gave me a hug there was
nothing really crazy they
have very high standards and uh tough
love but i think that i didn't really
need anything big from them i know that
just the smallest of congratulations
means a lot and for them to say they're
proud of me as well but they they were
very happy to have me home
life-changing experience emma you know
reporters paparazzi outside of your
house you are instantly recognizable
everywhere
are you ready for that how much your
life has now changed yeah i actually
haven't really realized because i just
came home and i've just been staying at
home spending time with my family so i
haven't really gone out or done anything
yet so i don't really see at the moment
any changes
well you've been super busy since that
match point you've done loads of things
at new york you've done chat shows
you've been to the met gala
well you looked fantastic
what was the highlight of all those
things that you did because you won
thank you i think the highlight
of my time after the final was honestly
that night that of the final i just
spent it with my team in
morning
i'll join later
thirty years ago nirvana released their
second album never mind which catapulted
the band and its front man kurt cobain
to international fame still hugely
popular despite the death of cobain in
1994 here's our arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer
[Music]
stephanie phillips was only three years
old when never mind first came out
i think those four opening chords are
just really kind of revolutionary to me
like so many who own the album its songs
are now second nature anyone can play
them and that's why i love them
[Music]
shortly after nevermind's release the
small alternative rock group from
seattle would become one of the biggest
bands in the world a defining record of
the grunge movement
[Music]
they said to a lot of their fans if
you're going to be racist or homophobic
don't come to our shows don't buy our
records we don't want anything to do
with you which is a really clear stance
and could be like derided as cancer
culture now but back then it was just a
band being political and being honest
but would the album have been as talked
about if kurt cobain was still alive
i've never really understood why people
rave about never mind 30 years on to be
honest music writer everett true was a
friend of the band they just had a
wicked sense of humor you know you just
get up to the most mischief you possibly
could setting curtains are like a light
and dressing rooms thing you know they
did the whole kind of cliche band thing
for a while kind of throwing tvs out the
window kirk cobain's rockstar antics off
stage might not have been relatable but
his weariness and frustration on the
recording spoke to the disillusioned the
disenfranchised
[Music]
that screen really did you know
capture that kind of feeling of angst of
loneliness of just not being able to
cope with the outside world
[Music]
it is impossible to list all the artists
who cite nirvana as a formative
influence
i think it caused a lot of guitar
players to retrain and suddenly they're
sort of hiding their
technical ability which can be a bit
spidery and there was all these guys
that um
i would be in football teams with
who showed no interest in music at all
and then within about
three months of never mind coming up
they're all playing guitar
they're
[Music]
they led a cultural rebellion rejecting
the mainstream and 30 years on to
successive generations that rage is just
as raw katie spencer sky news
[Music]
one of the biggest cancer fundraising
events takes place this month we'll talk
to two of those who've raised tens of
thousands through tea and cake next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
southeast asia correspondent in bangkok
[Applause]
[Music]
very much to eat at all a lot of them
extremely thin and very frail
the people here are praying quietly to
themselves
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
now they're trying to finish the job off
so they can move into the square
[Music]
okay it's okay two words okay
they're becoming very sensitive
having the media around
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment at all
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
every time they touch and they spray
sprayed spray
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
to the vineyards
i can't imagine
how much plastic
is lying at the bottom of this huge lake
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
the weather continues to be warm for the
time of year today it'll be central and
eastern areas that see the best of the
sunshine whilst low cloud patchy rain
and drizzle will tend to spill its way
in from the northwest we are looking at
a top temperature of around 24 degrees
celsius that's 75 degrees fahrenheit
it'll be breezy everywhere with some
gales across the northern isles this
afternoon and those strong winds are
actually
helping with the air pollution levels
which look like staying low throughout
the day
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
a cuppa for cancer one of the biggest
annual events to raise funds for people
living with cancer takes place later on
today let's find out more about the
world's biggest coffee morning joining
us is macmillan fundraiser caroline
mallon and also breast cancer patient at
jenny powell hello to you both thank you
for joining us on the programme um
caroline to you first of all tell us
about the macmillan coffee morning for
those who don't know about it
well i started with the melancholy
morning about 15 years ago after
seeing an advert in the good
housekeeping magazine and
seeing to raise money for for charity
from the villain um
i can't run a marathon but i can bake
so i started in the city 15 years ago
and raised my first coffee morning
625 pounds
and 16 16 years later i've now raised
just over 30 000
and
i have
people coming to my house making amazing
and i sell baking i do a raffle lucky
dip
lots of different things and it's just
become something every year that i do i
start baking um in may
and i meet jam
um
i've got john here raspberry jam
um i made apple pies chocolate fudge
um and yes it's it's a it's a lovely
event and it's something that i can do
from macmillan cancer supports that's
amazing good for you good for you and
jenny it makes all the difference to
people like you doesn't it because it
helps um bolster the funds of mcmillan
how did macmillan help you
and so macmillan kind of helped they
helped me from the very start as soon as
i found out that i had cancer i
um there was a lady called emma who's my
macmillan nurse and she has been there
emotionally supporting me
supporting my family
and
i also have a lady called debbie who's
part of the macmillan welfare advisor
and she's helped me
so um
coffee morning's help obviously to raise
money for macmillan
and macmillan gave me 350 pounds grant
which um that helped me to fund all of
my surgical bras and wigs and just
anything that i kind of really needed to
take the stress away from
everything which was amazing
that's brilliant um caroline how do
people get involved if they want looking
at pictures there jenny as we're
chatting to you caroline how do people
get involved uh with accounts with the
coffee morning if they want to or um
have the resources
well and you you and just on the
macmillan website and they send you a
pack with things like um flags and
invitations
and i mean
lots of people do
a coffee morning and they only raise 100
pounds they just have their friends and
you don't need to be you can just even
buy
um
things from supermarket and
up here i've got my my donation boxes
and you can do it online or whatever but
every small amount counts from macmillan
whether it's 50 pens a pound
and and sometimes shops
have the restaurant have the coffee
morning but i just do it in my own house
and i have all my family helping me i
have friends helping you on the day it's
not just really about me it's about my
family
and because it's five months out of my
year but again you can just do it you
can just go to a shop and buy some some
things
have tea and coffee and ask people for
donation every penny counts as 98 of um
macmillan is funded by and people like
me
and
so that that's that's how you do that
that's amazing looking at pictures of
you there is as we're chatting um jenny
tell me about um how you're getting on
with
your cancer diagnosis we've seen some
pictures of you there jenny and um it
does look i mean looking at you this
morning you look as though you're doing
very well
yes thank you so um i found out in
november that i have breast cancer
and in the december actually it was the
23rd so two days before christmas i had
my mastectomy i've had radiotherapy in
may but i have the all clear now i am on
medication for the next 10 years but
apart from that it's all good
that's absolutely um amazing you've got
lots of baking behind you and what do
you do today
so we i actually work at sean's bakery
in redborn so we are doing a coffee
morning here we've been running it since
monday
and today is going to be the final day
so we're really going to be pushing it
and i think we've raised a total of 750
pounds so far but we do have a facebook
link of amazon
just to top up there
that's absolutely amazing have a great
day ladies hopefully you'll raise lots
of money for macmillan and it's good to
uh talk to you this morning especially
with those magnificent displays behind
you thank you both very much indeed
thanks a lot thank you